I've never used steam controller mode
before but maybe this will make my
controller work much it's working
chicken oh I was I guess I don't have
anything in a hot head that's who I was
right yes that's right all right sure
yeah okay I'm ready don't you actually
have a skin in this game oh yeah well I
don't have it right that's gone forever
I have no idea did I join your game wid
oh hey boy completely forgotten how to
play so I know this sliding though and I
know there's like a grappling hook and I
used to be good at that hey we had so
many more levels what happened to us oh
wait do you guys have levels I don't
have any levels no I don't have to
select at random workshops oh okay see
what happens okay into opponents Oh jack
will have know how to play oh okay okay
all right why is the rapid WASD okay
there oh boy oh wow well the bot is
gonna make us look really bad
okay oh great all right guys none of my
buttons swim oh [ __ ] what's slime why is
that slide why would that be slide looks
like why why yeah why is why slide oh
what's that's not right no boy boots
I don't know man I don't know how do I
use an item oh god that's not it all
right next game I'm gonna set up my
controls again cuz man this is dead oh
god oh god help okay I'm fine okay well
the bot is making us look absolutely
terrible
yeah you guys could leave the starting
line oh boy press y to save this replay
yes please
okay I'm gonna go change my controls
real quick
to configure controller please either
enable the steam overlay or use this
option or what I don't want steam do you
have to do that can't change controller
without oh I have controller
configuration as an available option all
right how do I enter big picture mode
all right good thanks
didn't really configure the [ __ ] out of
these controls huh rolls I hate I got a
turn on the other leg I'm sorry what was
that
I hate yeah that's it that's it that's
all I said oh okay now if I click on
this it just doesn't do anything are you
kidding me what let me configure my
control mark I don't know if we have
time for this man what are you doing
Marcus is an invite Marcus is a play
mark I think Wade sent you an invite oh
wait I got it okay here we go
all right Marcus it's an invite hang on
you you're gonna you're gonna like this
wait you're gonna laughs are we gonna
have yeah did you get the invite mark
what in the world double check that
invite mark mark do you resubmit invite
another invite mark I send you another
invite I've fixed it I've fixed it it's
like something invite I'm just gonna go
random workshop [ __ ] all right that
button is grayed out for me I don't know
man I don't know man
that's that's not the button I set that
to what are you doing no no business
that's not that right all right whatever
I'll deal with it it's okay I'm in the
lead are you though yeah yeah it's all
good yeah oh [ __ ] oh god oh god no don't
do it like this don't do me like this
okay I've got this yeah yeah yeah I
remember you Oh how do we boost am i
boost doesn't seem to be working
was there a boost button yeah if you get
loose I don't know man what's the boost
blood
I think it's right trigger by default
but I'm not a hundred triggers how I
moved in general what's why no what what
what I didn't move till I pressed right
trigger what'd you guys do move I don't
know [ __ ] I just push right here's a
controller right with joysticks are you
familiar with joysticks guys wait guys
oh no that's dance I have no idea what
boost is I think I know I'm going I'm
dying
that's not the buttons or something I
don't know I don't understand I have no
idea this is just messing with my brain
I've got I've got like repeat buttons
all across my controller
I know ice it's all broken left bumpers
boost for me for some [ __ ] reason
oh yeah mine too oh boy oh boy I'm out
of boots you [ __ ] dicks wait what Oh
scary wait mark what what I'm sorry I
can't do that wait oh yeah oh yeah this
is the wrong way oh yeah not today no I
can't wait now can't
your master yeah Java master barely
losing oh my god dad yes you master
knitting shuffle
oh no that's not the button that's not
about what foot and slide that's not the
button god damn it I still won I don't
even know what button climb is I've
learned it now but it's not intuitive
like I designed it to be what is
happening Oh God that's what you get for
being you
I don't know where we're going where are
we going Oh God oh no I'm dancing why do
I dance why is that button dance chit
chit chit no God stop down it's either
savant or - it's one or the other and it
keeps changing god I got it okay I need
to figure out which one of these what's
taunt what's okay is this taunt that's
not ton this is boost now it wasn't
boost just before it's a trap Jason be
clocked for your life wait or just let
the bot kill itself
I did I did that one that's fine wait
you did a good job
oh oh god wait which way am I going
which way am I going I don't know it's
way
which ways which ways right oh wait [ __ ]
it's just a [ __ ] trap Oh guys I died
all right good
I'm happy you're good I had a point I'm
happy oh no net pull a dinghy is real
ope stop doing that
oh god oh god no no no no no I'm not
like this how do how do you how do you
what No
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] no no I get so confused
by that source what you she's eating
about Oh guys wait okay you die you die
no you die you're not supposed to be
[Music]
just hang on wait yeah it's gonna happen
Oh God Oh what I don't know man yes yes
but just wait what's that
ow just wait what's up wait a minute
what talking why my taunting don't like
you've won you got a point you got to
what we went away we'll win you got
points points are better than winning
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you still have a chance why are you in
last place well cuz you won what suck
boxes [ __ ]
Oh God why do I talk why do I talk I
just taught at random times I mean
[Laughter]
good Wow
why in god's name did all of my buttons
get re re swagger thy buttons are fine I
still don't know what taunted my buttons
are so ruined yeah hang on let me see
this what oh wait I'm not ready what are
you guys doing dicks
god dammit the UP button is taut I'm
using the directional pad so up is taunt
[Laughter]
[Music]
that helped you know just cuz you're
dressed like a chicken doesn't mean you
need to actually sound like a chicken oh
boy oh you really got me wait I have a
chance
alright you [ __ ] does that mean I'm
feeling a mite on balls stop with the
boxes chicken Bob what that's not good
no no not like this who put a box at the
bottom of the goddamn Pig nothing like
this no you won't so I'll see you Osama
I'm seeing you right now oh yeah I'm
seeing you don't do it don't do it don't
do it no wait wait okay that guy works
hey uh-oh that's it what oh wait last
time alright guys I'm back in it you
guys get ready for a I got an idea here
I got the strats oh you figured are you
laughing but watch this super speed see
I got that I got the moves oh yeah yeah
what of it
Oh God oh yeah I'm so into myself oh
yeah we don't balls for good what what
what's up more boxes there apparently
don't you dare
oh god you're welcome let's talk about
this wait let's talk about this don't
you
holy [ __ ] ways a master no he's not a
master he's an amateur alternate God
training ultimate god oh wait wait what
um what here I go I guess alright come
on got him right there the boss doesn't
seem to be able to do it either Wade or
Bob jump up here I'm gonna grapple out
of here ha I know there you go no I
tried to grapple you well now what how
the hell do but it's just another what
they're like some advanced technique
that speed run always no I know what to
do this I got a guy that's right here
it's right there okay I'm gonna open the
door come back what what's up I open the
door for you alright it's a teamwork one
well I think the AI is done
that's fine oh oh oh dear what the hell
oh I see yeah yeah ha ha [ __ ] did you
get it oh I can force surf maybe hang on
wait so this oh I see if you guys see it
oh I see it
Oh I jumped over it Jesus what Oh No
hey Mark yeah yeah mark help I can't
[ __ ] I don't like this I can't help what
are you doing
I think it's any smaller than that well
so Bob won one round I guess that means
you won I am the champion how do I get
out exit there we go okay all right
we're doing great guys oh cool
man it's really working I can't be
hothead cuz the bot is hot oh well ro
here it's fine it's fine it's fine
we had lucky I'll be the normal guy
there okay all right why do I have
nothing unlocked I thought I had
everything I thought they like should
all have it was like you've never played
this game before
yeah it said the same to me hey it's us
oh [ __ ] no wait hang on don't do that
what leave leave me behind way
this is just a regular map I though yeah
they'd reskin dit I remember this one
whoa okay well [ __ ] down what would you
say if you wanna [ __ ] down come on I
think he does well that's the man you
guys are really swinging ever [ __ ] man
it's [ __ ] anywhere will do don't
worry
I'm coming for you oh sure there's
nothing to worry about here no no no not
like this
Oh Marc oh missile oh god stop oh man
so weigh the [ __ ] no it's the way
the cookie crumbles oh yeah it seems to
be boxes Oh turns out it was boxes the
whole time why am i moving in slow
motion
maybe maybe you need to get good maybe
you need to get good good man [ __ ]
listen mark don't you're really doing
ahead don't do it don't do it please
don't get too far away from me and I
won't help you do it where am I going
where am I going yeah talk about yes
[ __ ] you no no don't you you won't know
balls uh-huh no thank you
oh that didn't really help me hey that's
what you get that's what you get god
yeah you guys yeah
wait hey come on now yeah what of it
what of it what I'm one of it one of it
wait that's really [ __ ] rude yeah it
was kind of a dick move
mark please do it do it - do what forgot
you scary guys how are you gone my bro
oh it's gone oops the nightclub oh wait
out here spamming all this [ __ ] booze
straight all blowing his boost load yeah
so let's tone it down a little bit let's
toner now we I remember there's a way to
like stay up in the air like this entire
path have you do it right oh no okay I
win by default
oh wait ice beam me [ __ ] that's my bed
oh not this no no no I like this no not
like this not like this it's coming for
you baby it's coming for you Oh God Oh
skill we damn it know been a lot of fun
and games but uh time to put the baby oh
[ __ ] No
don't put the [ __ ] big you you laugh
yeah you laugh yeah you laugh okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no I don't know where I'm going I don't
know what that does I have a oh I
thought I was not myself for being you
no no no no no we're not good that part
all right okay all right wait where are
we going wait wait wait I'm going on
here wait a minute this is the play wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
yeah oh wait this is a play well you
guys do play yep yeah that's the one no
no I did I did the thing thank you for
giving me okay okay okay you see this
why what like now now that we do that
Bob [ __ ] wait stop
okay it's alright what's up there is
fine there's something up there nothing
there we go okay wait stop look even
know alright wait you soon you gonna get
the boxes that was this your own don't
lose to the bots why would I lose to the
bar BOTS look at me why would you want
that Wade nothing I said please don't
I'm going back for an item baby no mark
we're on the same team here hang on ways
this the funnel I don't know this is
luck how do you I don't know
wait you can do it why would you want
wait why wait cuz they're gonna win if
you get this one and I'm rockin yourself
uh-huh oh I never hit that no bow boy
that's not what I wanted either go go
climb climb run climb flee
Wade you got it Wade yeah don't do it
don't I said don't
I know but like why wouldn't I I don't
like that voice that's your Carol
Channing I forgot about that
yeah you don't remember do that in like
one move that doesn't make any sense huh
what your foot oh all right where the
[ __ ] are we this is the right way don't
worry about it oh no there's a sliding
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah we all want one we're all tired
we're all equally good at this great
litoris buddy clitoris what my clitoris
season he got me again Mike thank you
for the bits I was trying to read fast
oh look there's a lot of boxes I'm
sommore boxer listen guys you guys are
sassing me up pretty good but I'm gonna
do a maneuver you're gonna you're gonna
watch this and you're gonna love it
oh boy I'm really saw him really back
here did you love it did you love it oh
god I I used to be better about boxes I
swear
oh no wait hang on don't do that
chickens a real [ __ ] slide oh my god
mark oh yeah you sure did yeah yeah yeah
yeah sure did
hey wait how's it going I don't like
that chicken guy was chicken I think
he's a swell dude wait I forgot who I
was no not like this
guys please have mercy on my soul
guys I think we should kill that chicken
what's wrong the chicken I know it's
delicious I love chicken how do too I
eat my own kind I said it hold on mark
every way what you get that's we good
oh that would have been scary Bob would
have been scary didn't even come
anywhere near me Bobby are you made it
oh box he is he's deafened - awesome in
fact I don't if he's actually put bah
bah
alright just you and me Wade chicken man
alright that's all I needed to hear
see ya boxed me - no no no no no no no
you will die
oh thanks for taking that for me Bob why
do you get to grapples I don't know why
didn't you that's what you get like pop
like me when he comes back hey Mark you
want to slow the [ __ ] down for a second
nope
[Laughter]
are you done with the chicken
I say we daisy chain with daisy chain
will wade all the way back to the
beginning all right
oh why no fireball wait thank you oh god
yeah I'm never gonna play with now jump
do it does it do it - Joe oh there's a
lot of boxes up here yeah thanks for
clear those out for me bark bark bark
bark
what is that not even like it didn't
even faze you okay really
oh wait yeah
I literally immunity you're doing that
look this your you're ruining the
integrity of this stream so I've been a
jerk that's not telling me you're
clearly causing some repressed chicken
related memories Bob in a chicken
chicken I don't know man what
no problem well we shouldn't start
rumors but maybe maybe murmur Sibel
woman hey Bob hey Bob whoa I thought I
dodged it because it doesn't matter in
everybody kind of worked out for us all
right all right okay all right lucky wee
man wee man what are you talking wee man
nothing mark please did all the boxes I
will create more hate all the boxes on
the box
come on yeah I heard that guys how about
the risk of ending up in the spikes oh
no no that goes oh I'm going for it no I
didn't go for it all right
at least mark didn't win this one that's
well the bots gonna win cuz I can't
[ __ ] do it
oh no god what happened to me Todd [ __ ]
no I'm [ __ ] dead no you don't know
that jump through the gap hey I did it
might not have been the best advice oh
hey right here no listen stop
complaining and start running that's
today with the game speed one is speed
Juana's wanna know why does it not knock
you out what is I jumped what that
doesn't make any sense it's so excuse
oh my god okay well alright alright okay
alright oh yeah
you guys wanna keep going now which is
this a New Game+ 15 all right there was
no need for sass I was all right fine
you know what you know what fine it's
fine it is what it is and it's fine
guys wait I didn't get any boosts wait
hang on
oh god dang it well that's not the way
to go
[ __ ] me Aaron oh [ __ ] okay Oh No why did
I follow you idiot are we up here made
it nailed it I'm so good watch this it's
just a stupid computer
oh nice boo skip it's just the legendary
speed run boost skip all right the stick
move oh he didn't want those items did
you shush shush I [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] dead that's what I am that
was embarrassing
yeah yeah real and bleh losing no no why
me why me
I hate versus would who did it
ah no names
oh it's Wade that it's wait I'm just
gonna assume it's Wade whoa nice nice
nice nice nice huh
I mean I guess all right I haven't done
this right yet I didn't do it right but
that's closer the same yeah [ __ ] you oh
don't give a satisfied sigh
oh my god yeah I'm gonna dip into it's
just so peaceful
look no chickens just us it's just us
together playing get out playing games
see it's fun when friends play games
together it's hell but when when you
just stream by yourself solo streams all
the time it's it's good news for good
people there we go
ah that's the good stuff well
congratulations I got one thing to say
[Music]